[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESTON HUTCHINS: Hi.
My name is Weston Hutchins,
and I'm a Product Manager
for GKE On-Prem.
Even with more
and more workloads
moving to the public
cloud, On-Prem software
remains a necessity for many
enterprise organizations.
Every enterprise
has apps that are
difficult to move to the
cloud or restrictions
on where sensitive
workloads can run.
Many are looking for
a true hybrid story--
one where they can modernize
the apps for the cloud
but continue running in
their own data center.
Many companies have
looked to Kubernetes
to give them a consistent
environment between on-prem
and cloud.
But getting started with
Kubernetes is challenging.
There are over 50 distributions.
And choosing the right
tools to install Kubernetes
can prove daunting.
And then once you get a
cluster up and running,
you enter the land
of Day 2 operations
where you not only
need tooling, but
considerable operational
expertise to manage the life
cycle of a Kubernetes cluster.
We find a lot of
customers that start down
the route of building
their own in-house DIY
tooling to manage Kubernetes
later struggle to keep
that tooling up to date.
Google's answer for hybrid
is Cloud Services Platform,
a stack that takes the best of
cloud-native open technologies
like Kubernetes and Istio,
and lets you run them
in your data center.
But the key benefit of CSP
is the collection of cloud
services that integrate your
on-preming cloud workloads
into a single
unified experience--
services like binary
authorization for security,
unified login and monitoring
through Stackdriver,
or our centralized
policy management
that syncs access controls
across all of your clusters.
At Next '19, we'll deep
dive into the infrastructure
layer for CSP, GKE On-Prem.
GKE On-Prem takes all of
the technology behind GKE
and installs it on top of
VMware in your data center.
Once installed, you
register your cluster
with Google's Cloud Console
to give your administrators
and developers a single
pane of glass for managing
their clusters and apps.
In our talk at Next,
we'll take a detailed look
into a real-world use case.
Arctiq, one of our CSP
solution providers,
recently rolled out GKE On-Prem
to one of their customers--
Optiva, a telecommunications
services company.
We'll walk through
Optiva's architecture,
show how GKE On-Prem integrated
with their existing tools
and workflows, and give some
tips for your own installation
of GKE On-Prem.
Check out the breakout session
online, and we'll get you up
and running with GKE
On-Prem in no time.
[MUSIC PLAYING]